hey guys it's justine and today we have
a very very exciting unboxing i know i
say that quite often but this is
something
all new from dji this is their first
little baby steps into
fpv drone flying fev drones are
completely different than most of the
consumer drones that most of us are used
to flying i've done some fpv flying
before but not really that much so i'm
very excited to test this out without
further ado
we're gonna unbox and get to it
oh my goodness oh it's heavy
heavy boy
[Music]
controller let's get everything out
gosh there's so many goodies in here
this is an authentic smile
sometimes i smile and i'm crying inside
but this
is real there are no tears inside
holy crap i can't wait to take this out
looks like this
is some propellers so this is the a
propellers
this is the b propeller box they're also
red
tips i thought we were gonna get like a
different tip color so to be able to
identify which one is the a and which
one is the b
you'll see the inner circle of the a is
red
the b is black
oh shoot look at this oh
boy we've got some more boxes
that is a very
large power adapter
what's this
[Music]
oh my gosh i can change his outfit
oh oh oh wow look at all of this
like we're all gonna end up walking
around like this one day you know what
hi i'm justine nice to meet you
i'm covered negative so here's
everything that came
inside of the fly more combo kit now the
cool thing about this is yes it is an
fpv drone so you can fly
traditional fpv so if you do take your
hands off the throttles the drone is
going to drop
out of the air but they also have the
modes that we're familiar with in
previous dgi drones so you can't fly
this normally
this is really great way to kind of ease
your way into fpv drone flying the one
thing that i do want to note is
fpv drone flying has been around for a
really long time and a lot of these
pilots have worked
so hard to create their own drones most
of them are made
basically from scratch this is a way to
make it more accessible but i don't want
that to discredit all of the hard work
and effort and the time that all of
these pilots have put in
the years of building and perfecting
their drones
i see you we see you we don't forget
i'm a noob hi time to charge up the
batteries update the firmware
and i've got a lot to learn
[Music]
i've never been afraid to fly a drone
before but this is something that's
entirely different i'm not very
comfortable flying
fpv so this is kind of really like
my first big leap into it now the good
thing about this drone though is
i can fly it like a normal mavic which
i'm incredibly comfortable with
but you can flip this thing into sport
mode and you can go
so fast but thankfully there's really
not a lot of stuff that i can hit out
here
the real question that i'm asking myself
is am i going to be brave enough to pop
this into manual for the first time
in this video i'm not entirely sure i'm
a little bit nervous i feel like i kind
of want to work up to it
because i don't want to crash the drone
i have been doing the in-flight
tutorials there's an app
where you can race in different settings
kind of like a simulator
but nothing simulates real life okay
let's just do this let's just do it
let's just do it so here
she is
oh wow
that is aggressive nothing about this
drone is subtle
at all all right
no better time than now this is weird
it's like i'm outside my body
[Music]
so
oh i got so close to his car holy crap
that was so scary you guys i'm i'm still
learning my controls
eric i guess okay return to home i'm
just testing it out i normally
for me personally i never like to do
return to home i like to manually
land myself and surprisingly not feeling
much motion sickness
as i thought that i would have when i'm
playing the kind of like the simulator
i do feel a little bit of motion
sickness but because i feel like i'm
sitting
stable not moving my head a lot i feel
pretty good
i can't believe how much fun i'm having
dude i almost hit you
i'm about to take off on one more flight
the problem is these batteries aren't
charging fast enough
and i only have three so this is my
third flight and this is something that
i really want to test out this is the
motion controller so this is kind of an
all new way to control the drone it's
basically
gesture control here's your acceleration
there's a break so i'm not going to try
the motion controller out just yet
i'm still kind of getting my bearings
and i also only have one battery left
so i want to get a couple more flights
in before we don't have any batteries
left i am very excited though because i
am going to be meeting up with some of
my friends
and we're going to do an fpv drone
course race
together so i need to practice up and
get ready
for the big race i'm not confident in my
skills yet but
we'll see what happens she's going in
i am preparing for the tournament
tomorrow there's a big race that's
happening with jesse and some fellow
pilots
i'm so dusty going in
left towards jenna
towards me up up up up up
so that's the problem
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so we're in oxnard right now and there
is a drone competition that is about
to take place behind me they have this
course all set up there's small little
gates it's very close quarters and this
type of flying is something that i don't
ever
do i'm so used to flying just my mavic
drone getting cool cinematic shots
this is completely different when you're
in the fpv it's so much faster
the other thing that i've never
experienced in fpv is the um
proximity sensing there so like the jerk
that i am i tried to thread the needle
going down these orange groves
and it slowed it down like a really
consistent slow down and it was like
hey bro it's kind of a lot right now and
like it kept me from being reckless
is that is the pinch technique something
i should know about
it is that's what i use really but i
wouldn't i go
gamer technique i go like call of duty
calls
but you can't you can't do that you get
more precise this way
i guess i'm up first
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god yeah
so my natural reaction is like okay i'd
rather go up
when you went around these two gates
were zipping we're like oh wow
this is so cool this is such a fun
course if you guys want to check out the
full video that jesse did i'll put a
link in the description
and is my forehead dented yep
that
[Music]
well thank you guys so much for watching
i had so much fun testing out this drone
i
love flying fpv the thing that i do need
to do is
practice a little bit more but this kind
of really opened up my eyes to what's
possible
and the fact that dji is making this
easier and accessible for more people to
start flying
it's really cool and i'm so excited to
see what the future of this all looks
like
i have no idea where it is it's coming
up for us
like quick